I'm six foot six that's what's going on
here
six foot six which is a lot of Jew it's
like two Jews but I must admit that
despite this rather imposing one could
argue majestic physique I'm not like a
I'm not a man's man I'm unless the man
was Michael from Michael's Arts and
Crafts I think he would like me I love
Michael's I call it classy Joanne's
joins is nice but it's always in
disarray whereas Michaels is always an
array I grew up in the 1970s which was
not very accommodating to sensitive boys
I think I would have made a great
millennial they're much more accepting
and because to put it in put it in
millennial terms I have a Gryffindor
body but a Hufflepuff soul
I'm sweet in the 70s just kids were so
mean to each other I remember her played
junior high basketball and and even the
cheerleaders were antagonistic I felt
they would they would chant be
aggressive be aggressive Gary my fear
and why Millennials are nicer to each
other than we were growing up is that
Millennials grew up much better hydrated
than we did the water just was not a
consideration in the 1970s now I'm not
an old man comedian who's gonna say we
didn't even need water we needed it
desperately walked around dizzy and
listless all the time but a lot of times
I wouldn't get my first sip of water
until Thursday after Jim the teacher
would March us down to the drinking
fountain and the entire experience was
fraught how so how is it fraught Wow
water pressure in 1970s public schools
was so weak so so flaccid you had to
make love to the drinking fountain to
get a full quench but if you got that
close it tempted the [ __ ] behind you
to smash your skull into the steel spout
which was considered a prank in 1978
now now it's properly classified as
felony assault but in the 70s that was
just shenanigans the teacher wouldn't
even interrupts her countdown which
because of budget cuts classroom sizes
were enormous so the teacher
this was her constant one-mississippi
two-mississippi three-mississippi
goodbye and I I would get so outraged I
was seven years old but I was I was very
precocious I think he would have loved
me I would protest I would say mrs.
McNally that's her real name I will I
will protect her no longer she didn't
get back to me I would say mrs. McNally
it's not Mississippi its Mississippi
you're costing me an entire syllable of
hydration with your pidgin English but
you want to know something mrs. M how
appropriate
how app that you use Mississippi to
carry out this unjust drinking fountain
policy pad that is precocious
to have that firma grasp of Jim Crow
legal doctrine at seven is like the
epitome of precocity it's so great to be
back thank you so much for having me on
you